[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily parents accused of
letting their neighbors murder their
four-year-old daughter
their request to go to her funeral
denied one of the worst cases
actually the worst case any of us have
ever seen
prosecutors announced murder charges in
a mass shooting in illinois
how officers caught the suspect an army
special force sergeant
a witness who was on the first floor
during the incident told police that he
heard multiple gunshots
and saw the defendant mr webb with a gun
and a judge denies bond for elaine
maxwell
why jeffrey epstein's former
girlfriend's second request was rejected
she had 12 bank accounts three passports
plus body cam video from nashville
police officers
show the harrowing moments before a
bombing rocked the city
we look into the suspect's possible
motives and criminal background
building that's next to houses all the
hard lines for
phones throughout the southeast
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a couple in missouri is accused of
allowing their neighbors to beat their
four-year-old daughter
to death law encrimes anjanet levy is
here with the gruesome details
about the startling case yeah brian
criminal complaints for the four adults
charged in this case paid an absolutely
horrifying picture of what was going on
in that house
according to the father of the children
his neighbors beat his four-year-old
daughter
because they believed she was a demon
the only thing we have is what they're
telling us and they're
doing it in the name of uh discipline
you know disciplining the family was
their quote
there's a huge this huge difference
between discipline and
beating
now sheriff eric knox calls this the
worst case he's seen in his career
the criminal complaints state that
courtney almond and ethan mass started
beating members of the mast family five
weeks ago
with a belt and a wooden spoon sheriff's
deputies found james and mary mass
four-year-old daughter dead on december
20th
after james called 9-1-1 james told
deputies the neighbors convinced him
this was quote a god thing james said
his neighbors beat him
his wife mary and their four-year-old
daughter and also their two-year-old son
and that he allowed it to happen and
shouldn't have fallen for it
the four-year-old and mary were also
dunked in an icy pond
you know one one or more of them were
fanatics
like i said like i put in my facebook
post you know this is an isolated
incident you know
some people tried to say that this was
the cult because they
they used the word demon and obviously
demon and god in the same sentence
you know would cause speculation for
imaginations to run wild
but there's no evidence of anything
other than this family and
you know well basically two families
now there are a laundry list of charges
for all of the people charged in this
case
almond and ethan mast face second-degree
murder charges along with some other
counts
and then the mast family they face
charges of involuntary manslaughter and
also some other charges and more charges
could be filed we're told brian
after the medical examiner's report is
complete
is ethan mass related to james and mary
and how is a two-year-old doing you know
that's an interesting question
according to the criminal complaint
james mask told the deputies that to his
knowledge
he and ethan mast were not related it's
interesting to point out that
he told the deputies that ethan mast was
actually
found on a pamphlet it was a church
pamphlet found in his home
and that two-year-old little boy is
still in the hospital recovering from
the wounds he suffered from those
beatings
wow internet thanks for that update
absolutely sickening
now let's bring in co-host terry austin
for a legal analysis
terry i can't wrap my head around some
of these allegations
beating your child and forcing you to do
the same
do you think this could be a death
penalty case
yeah i do think it could be a death
penalty case you know in all likelihood
these individuals unless they say that
there was some insanity defense or maybe
they were coerced
in all likelihood the evidence is
pointing directly at them
and i do think that if in fact the
prosecution can impose the death penalty
they will this was a heinous crime
now very interesting that you brought up
the demons and and there's a fear of
retaliation and coercion and
self-defense not self-defense sorry but
coercion
do you think that's a possible defense
here coercion
i i do think coercion is a possible
defense what they're trying to say
is that this other you know two people
are you know coercing them to do this
and saying that they must do this
because there are demons but
you know the sheriff actually said that
there was no
evidence that there was any sort of cult
involved so
i don't know if that is actually going
to prevail
absolutely sickening and we'll see how
this plays out thank you terry
and now to ohio where city officials
have fired a police officer
after a fatal shooting
the columbus public safety director
announced the termination of officer
adam coy
the board's decision is upholding the
police chief's recommendation
coy was responding to a non-emergency
call about a parked suv
that had been running on and off he
encountered andre hill
standing inside a garage he'll step
towards the officer
holding his cell phone when coy fired
coy hit record on his body cam
nine seconds after the shooting but a
look-back feature captured 60 seconds of
video
before recording the incident put your
fucking hands out to the side
hands out to the side now
roll to your stomach now
a federal judge in new york has denied
the second request by elaine maxwell to
be released from jail on bond
maxwell is accused of helping
millionaire pedophile jeffrey epstein
sexually abuse girls the judge said
maxwell still poses a flight risk
despite her telling the judge she'd post
28 million dollars in bail
and pay for her own 24 7 security
prosecutors say maxwell
told them she's in the process of
getting a divorce from her husband
former federal prosecutor and law and
crime legal analyst gene rossi
agrees with the judge's ruling what
happened with
ms maxwell she got too cute by half
she's trying to
use the marriage as a sword and a shield
before she got arrested the marriage was
just a scam
now she's trying to use it as a shield
to keep her from being detained
and the spouse whoever he may be
he's being used and abused in my opinion
she had 12 bank accounts
3 passports she could go to either
england where she has a passport
or france and they rarely extradite or
not often extradite people
the other reason is this she was living
in the shadows when they arrested her
and she has every reason in the world at
her
age and facing these charges never to
come back
so it could have been 220 million and
she would have been detained
yeah i don't see her changing zip codes
anytime soon still ahead on law and
crime daily
an army green brain now faces charges in
a deadly bowling alley shooting
and later an inside look into the
moments surrounding the nashville
bombing
what alerted officers to an incoming
danger
[Music]
officials in illinois announced murder
charges against an
army special forces sergeant terry
austin has the latest
on this mass shooting brian duke webb is
accused of going on a deadly shooting
spree
at a bowling alley prosecutors say webb
is facing
three charges of murder and three
charges of attempted murder
for the incident in rockford records
show webb is a green beret
based out of pensacola florida the u.s
army says he was deployed overseas
four times police went to don carter
lanes on december 26
after receiving a call of shots fired
three people were killed and three more
are injured a sixteen-year-old female
was sitting at a table on the first
floor
with three other teenagers when the
defendant began shooting at their table
this female suffered a through and
through gunshot wound to the shoulder
she survived her injury a 14 year old
male was shot in the face
he is alive but hospitalized in critical
condition
sixty-five-year-old thomas furseth was
on the first floor
when the defendant began shooting mr
purcess began running toward the stairs
when the defendant shot him in the torso
he was able to run up the stairs before
he collapsed
he was dead at the scene when police
arrived
the defendant then went upstairs to the
second floor of don carter lanes
approximately 20 to 25 people were on
the second floor
the defendant fire fired several shots
at the people in the bar
he shot 73 year old dennis steinhoff in
the torso
mr steinhoff's body was recovered on the
balcony just outside the bar
69 year old jerome jerome woodfork was
on the second floor when the defendant
began shooting
mr woodfork's body was found in the
parking lot below the balcony
he suffered a gunshot wound to the neck
a witness saw him fall to the ground
from that balcony he was deceased when
officers arrived
prosecutors say defendant continued his
shooting rampage
through the bowling alley
a 62 year old male was in the bar on the
second floor
the defendant shot this victim in the
left eye
back neck groin and buttocks
this victim is alive but still in
critical condition
police officers located the defendant
inside the building and took him into
custody
the entire incident was captured on
video surveillance
the defendant admitted to the shootings
and directed officers to the locations
of the firearms
that he used two firearms were recovered
in that location
they were located behind a bag that
belonged to the defendant
the firearms were a glock 40 caliber and
a glock
380 caliber multiple 40 caliber and 380
caliber shell casings were found
at the scene one question that's arisen
is why was mr webb in rockford illinois
he was originally from florida
he was here on leave visiting family
criminal defense attorney and former
prosecutor julie randleman
joins terry and i for legal analysis
julie
defense attorney said webb showed signs
of ptsd and other traumatic brain
injuries they ask for a mental health
evaluation
is this a potential mitigation for a
plea defense a trial or maybe both
yeah i think it could be both i mean
they're already setting the stage this
is a a man i think he's 37 years old
he's done already
four tours in afghanistan we don't know
what he's seen what he's experienced
um but i think it's clear that the
defense is laying the groundwork
um to go after you know whether or not
this is a mental health issue
they've already talked about some memory
loss
as well as being a potential mitigation
or some type of defense
um so we'll see and i'm curious to know
what people knew about his mental health
before he ended up on leave with two
guns uh in his possession
especially people in the army that would
be good to know terry
bail was denied this time what's that
due to the case as the defense is
seeking to get
webb evaluated you know i think the
judge denied bail because it's clear
that
webb is posing a threat to the community
but
his attorney did say that she thought
that he did have
indications of ptsd in her press
conference she stated that she
was going to have him evaluated by
doctors and we'd have to wait to see
what they said but that was her thought
as well
yeah you got to make the argument but i
didn't see that bail argument really
working in this case
coming up on law and crime daily a
swearing defendant finds himself adding
more time onto his sentence
the courtroom video you don't want to
miss after the break
trust me when i say judges can hear a
lot of things from the bench
but cursing at them is never a good idea
long crime founder and host of the a
e series court cam tells us about one
inmate that didn't want
to keep their mouth shut christopher
colon
our next stop is at the broward county
courthouse in fort lauderdale florida
you've been charged with two counts of
violating an injunction
where christopher colon appears for his
bond hearing via video
before judge john hurley court finds
probable cause
colon was arrested and charged with two
counts of violating a restraining order
in a domestic violence case related to
his ex-girlfriend
he also has an open pending case in
which he's being charged for aggravated
battery against a pregnant woman
his current girlfriend i think i
remember you from before
coming into this courtroom yes sir i
remember
less than a month ago cologne posted
bond in the aggravated battery case
and went free so the judge isn't exactly
thrilled to see him again you're already
on bond
you're already out yes sir and my boss
man is willing to take me out again
on a barn that's very kind of him but
that won't be necessary today
because well i'll see you guys well i'll
see you guys in with a lawyer
and a lawsuit too oh okay oh wait bring
him back please
and you can go yourself too
cologne storms off would you bring it
back
don't mute that could you turn that mic
back on for me turn the mic back on
you guys can suck my you guys can suck
my
okay 125
000
in case 14 7168
cf-10 you'll be held without bond
that bond is revoked with the amount
seemingly
no issue the judge has just taken away
the bond
from the aggravated battery case meaning
cologne will not be able to go free this
time
and this really sets him off
like i said you guys can suck my while
you guys had it
sir at this time the court at this time
is inclined to hold you in contempt of
court
i don't give a fuck go ahead i got
lawyers i got lawyers man
i ain't got nothing to say man now i
will find you in contempt of court for
disrupting this court
now
opportunity is there anything you'd like
to do ain't nobody in hitler man
for me no comments
in your defense the court at this time
will sentence you
to 364 days in the broward county
thank you very much
yes sir thank you
mr colon please a week later cologne is
just
back in front of the judge
just hardly on i apologize what i did
i was wrong and not only i was wrong for
cursing you out
of the deputies hearing me curse you out
i'll apologize to them too
the honor i apologize real bad
and i'm asking for my accept my of my
my prodigy please be honest okay
apologies accepted it will be converted
to time served at this time
cologne's apology gets that additional
year sentence for contempt
cut down to time served but still gets
no bond on the aggravated battery case
and serves almost 14 months before he's
released
season three of court cam airs
wednesdays at 9 00 pm
when we come back the chilling recording
the nashville
bombing suspect played just moments
before the explosion
here for yourself next
[Music]
newly released body cam video gives a
first hand account into the moments
surrounding the bombing
in tennessee nashville police officers
headed down 2nd avenue just after 6 a.m
on christmas morning the officers
hearing a warning from an rv about a
possible explosion
went door to door warning people to
evacuate so you're not doing anything
wrong
you're not in trouble but there is
something serious
the recording from the rv can be heard
as the officers hurried past
that's so weird that's like something
out of a movie
at 6 29 a.m the bomb went off
the sound captured on an officer's body
cam
the site captured on street surveillance
video those same officers suited up and
rushed towards the scene
debris covered the street as the rv
continued to burn
the blast damaged more than 20 buildings
and injured at least three people
44 we need a 47 executive broadway for
officer
there's a hearing loss in authorities
identified 63-year-old anthony quinn
warner
as the suspect warner died in the
explosion
the tennessee bureau of investigation
said detectives matched dna found at the
scene
to warner's hat and gloves those
detectives now working to determine if
warner was paranoid about 5g
and targeted the atnt building hey man
hey go that way man i'm sorry
you're good you just go that way many in
nashville still searching for the y
dude trust me go that way please i try
to go off this morning
i know it keep going that way as far as
y'all can
joining me again are attorneys julie
rendellman and terry austin
terry incredible work by the officers
many lives saves
um likely many would have lost but for
their quit thinking
how did you react to hearing this story
when you first when it first broke
well brian that's exactly right bless
those officers who went running
towards the incident and not away from
the incident and
as you said they saved many lives my
first reaction was
what is the motive and i guess that is
what everyone is
asking the you know perpetrator actually
did this at a time when not many people
would be around
and also gave a 15-minute warning so
that people could be
cleared out of the area so you have to
wonder
what was the intent here it was a
suicide and
clearly he damaged property didn't kill
people was this a warning
so that's what i want to know what was
the motive
yeah julie that's the question on
everyone's tongue right now it's not
really clear
but we're digging into his background
we're hearing a lot of theories
potential suicide he was hunting uh
aliens in his pastime
belief in lizard men or lizard people
now that might not be a clear connection
to this but
where are we going with this whole
thought process of what the motive could
be
it sounds like um he clearly uh planned
to not survive this incident and i say
that because he had already done certain
things prior to
the explosion i.e i believe he had given
away his car
he had transferred his home to someone
else without even getting paid so it
seemed clear that he did not
intend to survive and one of the i think
it was a neighbor said that when she
asked him about christmas his statement
was
um the world is never going to forget me
and so one wonders if
he had hoped to leave something for
everyone
um to remember him by thanks julian
thank you all for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
to discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you